hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage the show will be sit-down
with your favorite comedians and find
out if their trash I'm your host H Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day here at
club Foley just a stone's throw away
from the great city of Philadelphia I
can see the fireworks from here my good
pal Kevin Ryan back in the New York
groove up there holdin it down in the
heights the uptown uptown they call it
let me tell you something gang when
you're reaching for a best pal making a
kippie cuz this kids all right give it
up for Kevin James Ryan everybody I
really don't like that you're pushing
that slogan every [ __ ] week happy to
be here everybody thanks for listening
back in NYC for a couple of days to get
some supplies and then I headed back to
the boardwalk jersey shore baby that's
where I'll be yes if you haven't already
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes and I can subscribe
on YouTube to watch the full video as
well my man and let's get into a gang we
are so happy to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today
he's a get we wanted him we got him you
demanded him and now he's here you've
seen him on Comedy Central
talking sports and other things pot
don't lie with Sam Morrell Stav Esau's
problems the web series check out his
youtube channel and of course he's one
of the [ __ ] town boys dang it
he's the [ __ ] Prince of Baltimore
he's the pride of Greece you [ __ ]
know him you love him he's a sexy guy in
a tight little package and the word on
the street he's got a pretty decent
beast on him for Stavros halkias
everybody
Thank You Sean Foley thank you brother
listen I was with you until that last
one let's not you got a bad huh it's not
a good it's not good it's one of the
listen I've accepted it as a I've leaned
into body positivity everyone nobody
forgets peanut a penis is a part of your
body so if we're talking about plus-size
models and you know all kinds of people
it's like we got it we got to include
the little dick community so LD say baby
I'm not I'm not ashamed of it but I do I
want it out there that it's not a good
penis that out there yeah I don't know
I'm glad I'm glad the words out there
thanks to whoever is spreading that
whatever great gal is spreading that is
not true
it was Jeff Ross so I good me too man
I've had to lean into it to the fatter I
get the smaller it gets oh yeah
the worst the harder it is for me to get
to it it's bad news man mm-hmm
yep thank the Lord for dick pills making
it so that you don't have to come you
don't have to face yourself and
recognize you're a 30 year old man whose
penis doesn't work now without taking a
long hard look in the mirror always
always got one in the chamber
I like how you had on there waiting this
to me like maybe Foley's wearing
something revealing that uh
I need to jump up yeah oh when I get to
the point where I need to take big pills
for video sex then we're in a real
problem she's gonna mean that's a real
issue yeah that's no good
you gotta keep the only fans going you
know what I mean I've thought about it
so high a little bit there's there's a
market for everything
Foley there ain't a market for you
research I never come across anything
like you somebody out there would want
to see my butt hole I'm telling you that
I agree I agree with that most doctors
don't even want to see her but I don't
think your insurance covers that keep it
moving doc I think I appreciate cancer
well your [ __ ] get out my office Stassi
I think I have somewhat of an idea of
your story I know you did you grow up in
the city of Baltimore proper yep
Yeah right I'm not one of those [ __ ]
who claims to be from a city and is from
a suburb that always makes my blood
especially with Baltimore where it's
like there's a big difference you know
oh yeah but no I grow up I grew up I
grew up in South East Baltimore
Greektown yeah I grew up there when the
City School is the whole thing and I
basically lived in Baltimore the whole
time until I moved yeah I did I did
comedy in DC so I write mute essentially
it's like an hour away and yeah I lived
in Baltimore for until I moved here when
I was 25 26 and your mom and dad are
from Greece like originally like they
came here yeah they came here in the 80s
so and they owned a diner in Baltimore
is that kind of wish yeah absolutely
there's a mustache on what is war your
parents owned a diner no my father's a
carpenter who built a lot of diners and
I've spent a lot of time listen I spent
my first year listen I don't you think I
have any in a diner yeah of course
elicit that is the the the economy in
Greektown really is like diner diner
Britain like my dad was very much
depending on the on the
the diner economy just to you know build
furniture all this kind of [ __ ] put in a
bar he I mean every Greek restaurant
might there's a good chance my dad has
built something in some sort of booth or
something yes within you know a hundred
miles of Baltimore does anybody run a
diner better than a Greek family that is
we do crush that first oh my god I know
why that is stuff I have I have no idea
whatsoever I did you doesn't make sense
I think I agree people are weird uh they
they did kind of find their niche in
America just kind of we don't really run
any industries we don't really do it's
like we we are industries kind of
developed around you know the the cities
that we were in so diners you know
laundromats like carpenters all that
kind of [ __ ] just like on businesses
where you didn't really need an
education you had to learn the craft
it's like and then as well
that's kind of where they they got their
foothold but yeah it's really true that
the diner
whether it's like up and down the East
Coast and even in like Detroit it's
Greek people that run those two which
that doesn't make any sense to me
eastern seaboard at least could kind of
see but sure I don't know I have no
[ __ ] clue why well I don't ma'am yeah
dude I first found it my first diner
time first time I ever met a Greek dude
when he was running a diner that my
cousin was working at yeah and he made
me a grilled cheese and he made it with
[ __ ] mayonnaise on it instead of
butter blew my [ __ ] socks off I was
like I don't know what a Greek person is
Jeezy dude we will throw that's the
thing about there is no regard for human
life when a Greek person is chef it'll
be delicious but you'll be like wow
you're like I didn't even know I can't
feel my toes anymore these are this year
I've ever had their like yeah there's
three sticks of butter in it just fruit
loops with whipped cream instead of its
heavy cream instead of milk isn't it
good I don't know why we do yeah what
did I what did your mom do while you
were gone did she stay at home yeah she
actually was a waitress in a Greek
restaurant so that is so I had there's a
lot of leftovers waiting for her to come
back in the weekends just like a fat
boy honestly honestly watching SNL
that's when I start watching as I was
the only thing on at 11:30 wait for them
to get back and bring home tins of
calamari while I do I do love calamari
it doesn't hold that well though it
listen baby this place is good shouts
out to econo surveillance tell them
stuff II sent you try the Panama all
right great let me tell you something I
worked in a place in the West Village
that made taramosalata yeah I would
literally eat it until I got sick it's
incredible and this is caviar it's like
whipped caviar for the uninitiated and
it's I think it's [ __ ] it's delicious
its humble its kind of clogged your
heart so [ __ ] bad
absolutely and that's what I mean even
great people even took caviar like a
[Laughter]
scar dude that needs a little mayo and
[ __ ] four pounds of bread with it
let's go exactly did you have brothers
and sisters growing up are you an only
child I'm the oldest of three my brother
might have twin younger brothers they're
two years younger than me Wow
that's awesome yeah it was nice and I
was like very I mean it's very much the
immigrant like firstborn [ __ ] that I had
to deal with where it was like you know
I also was like I was pretty good at
school I was like a good test taker and
you know how [ __ ] schools work it's
like they decide whether you're smart or
not in second grade you know and I was I
happen to be good at like standardized
tests and I was like a good you know
whatever and I was a mouthy kid so it
was like my parents just thought that I
was my mom was one of those moms that
thought I was like going to Harvard at
11 you know what I mean like that was
that smart so yeah it was like I was the
oldest and I always had you know I was I
was considered the meal ticket for the
faith they were hoping I'd be like a
lawyer or something
senator halkias yeah honestly yeah I was
I interned at a at the Maryland assembly
house when I was in college yeah when I
was in college I was like yeah with the
school in like a policy scholar
and it's crazy to think that that I am
the same guy is that the world cuz I am
I've just ruined my brain in the
intervening 12 years but you know what
University of Maryland Baltimore County
so it's like UMBC they're richer
actually you know the team to beat
Virginia this is first sixteen seat that
would be the number one so yes
absolutely finally have so I finally
have something yes we're because before
it's like we're they're like Oh
University of Maryland's like no the one
the one literally thirty minutes closer
to Baltimore not the Terps the
Chesapeake Bay Retriever we did a type a
subtype of retriever the old the old
Bay's yeah honestly there's a lot but it
was a good school you know it was like I
it was like a local school obviously and
they had they had like they wanted to
like invest in Baltimore a lot so they
had like partnerships with the high
schools and there was they had great
scholarship programs and I mean like a
lot of my friends that I went to [ __ ]
school with are like doing big [ __ ]
they're like you know they're involved
in Maryland you know the politics a lot
of them like went on to go to like grad
school you know IVs and all that kind of
[ __ ] but I was just I just could not do
any of that stuff man it was clear it
was clear to me that I didn't want to do
it by the time I was at finishing school
for sure if the quarantines taught me
one thing it's that if I ever have to
work a regular job again or do something
like that I'll [ __ ] shoot myself oh
yeah never this was like the breaking
point I couldn't go back yeah we'll see
that's interesting you say that because
to me I'm almost like to me it's almost
like well my old way of life is over
like maybe I need to move to Baltimore
just and open a diner like Napa now I'm
almost like I can't do an office job
don't get me wrong that's out but that's
some honest work you know what I mean
overcharging people for grilled cheeses
yeah dude you can charge me whatever you
want for that girl cheese dog yeah
honestly I've gotten into light I
started grilling like my mother like
this is the most I it's funny cuz it's
like I think especially stand-up
comics but especially people in our
generation it's like well we're like I'm
31 like this is the I should have a kid
sure historically speaking and now I'm
just becoming a dad without a child I'm
just growing constantly like I'm
literally like checking just like and
I'm like damn I'm I think I'm ready to
just have for my life to catch up I just
want to have a kid do a podcast go on
the road once a once a month and just
grill and every opportunity that's
honestly what I want out of my life
that's clean living right there exactly
all I want I don't need I don't need
anything I don't have any more
aspirations it's over I want to be on TV
just let me podcast and let me go to the
funny bone
once a month II and have money for rib
eyes I'm [ __ ] good I just want one
kid wife and a nice like woman that
treats me better than I deserve is that
so much to ask now now you're a girl out
of your league and a Weber grill buddy
I'm sound but you just said that I'm
salivating we just want to keep keeps
toffee and [ __ ] tomahawk steaks
that's always Nathan covered I just
crushed a couple rib eyes for Father's
Day yesterday oh we did we did a couple
racks of ribs on the trigger smoker I
was out there all day we're doing a
brisket on [ __ ] Wednesday this is the
most excited I've been for anything ten
years gonna be gone in three minutes
[Laughter]
yeah I'll do the trigger those things
are [ __ ] awesome yeah I really are I
honestly don't move on because if we
don't I'm gonna be asking you about
grilling and smoking for the next 40
minutes so please ask me your questions
well let me ask you this we want to get
into some are you garbage questions here
I'm curious deep down like on the
surface you know that all that stuff yes
but do you think you're garbage
oh yeah for sure absolutely I think I I
think I mean I think it's pretty hard
not to be garbage the world is so bad
that if you have decided to do stand
comedy you're garbage for sure like we
could all be social workers we could be
teachers we could even be like garbage
like we could be serving society what we
do has no value whatsoever it's also
served as well it's no sure there's a
couple thousand people that might be sad
if all we stopped doing our podcast
stopped doing stand-up but you know what
for the most part they you could keep
watching movies that's one thing this
has taught me is like there's so many
movies there's so there's like Ed people
who will go watch there's enough you
know people can pick Joe Rogan or Amy's
they can pick the big ones and like them
it's like we are not helping the world
at all I quit being an after-school
tutor in Baltimore City to focus on open
mics my definition I'm a garbage human
being I've made my peace with it and I
live I live in my little trash Palace
right now but I know that's what it's
made of I know that's what the walls
around me are constructed of it's
garbage
so yes I do think I am garbage for sure
oh my god well we're gonna find out here
because I want to see I want to see I
want to see how the how they happy his
family uh how everybody grew up over
there and find out what's what oh yeah a
couple of the basics now you lived you
said you lived in the city limits did
you guys live in a single-family home
Mormon who's a town house breakdown is
like that's that's the you know it's
like grow houses like row houses yeah it
was a real Ellis Island style upbringing
me I share a wall with my grandmother
you know what I mean my little brother's
my little brother shared a room and my
parents lived like their their bedroom
was downstairs where the living room was
then the basement was the kitchen so it
was like you know too many and at a
certain point there was one point where
my cousin lived with us for like a few
years so how'd you cousin
she was mom she's a year older than me
so she like she there you know she moved
in with us her dad was a piece of [ __ ]
she moved in with us for a while you
know yeah I mean it's it's true so if
you want to talk historically speaking
yes my favorites garbage trash the
kitchen in the basement that's a time
your kitchens underground that's like
that's like fallout shelters yeah that's
and that was a bit yeah we used to have
a 2k used to be apartments and they like
there was one kitchen upstairs and one
kitchen downstairs and they they went
with the kit the basement one yeah but
yes no we're trash for sure there's some
custody battles in there my uncle was a
piece of [ __ ] my dad was a piece of [ __ ]
it's you know it's all it's all it's all
trash baby does anybody do it you have
any family members that currently don't
talk to each other like you're like oh
we can't go over you know or you know oh
me and my dad you know what I mean like
we don't you know but yeah in Greece
there's like feuds about some disrespect
at a barbecue that happened like in 1994
that like my second my dad's second
cousins they can't get they won't get in
a room together I love that sir sir yeah
yeah I mean I'm lucky in that it's like
it's like it's almost like when you know
you get the vanilla chocolate swirl and
that's me with because I have non
garbage family and I have their streaks
of me that are not garbage but it's
intertwined it's a there's no separating
them that's our favorite thing is that
like we realize everybody has it's like
a constant struggle like the garbage
part of you first important no it's
better and you're like I can't I can't
help it you know what I mean totally my
mom's cool my brothers are good people
so you know there's there's there's some
good in there for sure but yeah what was
what was the name of the grocery store
that your mom went to growing up where
would you shop Oh interesting
China I mean we did we were for sure we
had stance at those like discount
markets where there's no there's no
refrigerator
you know those wait yeah it's like
there's like if you're good if they're
getting meat that's in coolers
you know the bags are cereal they're
like that are like you know grain feed
like for horses like we definitely had
substance since they're for sure to my
mom's credit I didn't realize we were
poor
for my whole childhood I just may not
know so that's always you good at hiding
it for sure
I didn't realize it until we went to
until was like college you know when you
have to like do FAFSA or whatever it is
and they're like yeah now put in your
assets and and I was like mom what about
our assets she was like zero and I was
like I was like oh this is a language
barrier things like how much does how
much total money including our two
things we are like I know it's zero like
we're in debt I've been poor this whole
time I'll put my monocle and cigarette
holder away yeah so we spent some time
at those grocery stores and there was
one called santoni's - I was like a
total like local chain that I don't
think it's still there anymore Santoni
sounds classy though it's absolutely not
it's just absolutely not it's I know you
mean because there's a there's a there's
a classy one that's like really
hoity-toity like suburb one called
Balducci's and I guess you didn't know
those two you would think they are just
the Italian in themselves yeah a nice
Italian market that's what I would write
yeah yeah one is one is like you know
having go you know one is it's the
difference between going to like a nice
Italian like steak house and then going
to getting [ __ ] Olive Garden you know
what I mean like Carabas or something
yeah exactly
okay what do you got kept all right
while we're on food a little bit well if
you are at a grocery store how do you
feel about the free sample stuff oh I'm
all in are you kidding me do you don't
ever double battle I double double down
okay
it depends will you like dip if there's
a good thing I like hummus or like I'm
not double dipping come on
but you'll you'll sit there and like
you'll you'll dip a chip like you're
hanging out at a barbecue that's
interesting I I don't know that I would
dip but I will absolutely if there's
like a nice little piece of pound or
some cheese or something like if the
[ __ ] is good I'm getting more than one
and I might buy my kid three I'm I've
know I've been known to go for it in
fact
in my head I'm sometimes I'll just
real quick but sometimes I'm a gentleman
about I'll take a stroll around
yeah that's hell will you stop though I
forgot oh this is pineapple cake here I
don't remember if it was good or not and
I'm still considering buying it so maybe
I'll have another [ __ ] just to my no one
gives a [ __ ] could not care less
why don't we only send every cuz I do
social anxiety you get so funny yeah in
us we didn't pull him on over on them
you know what I mean I got it would give
one to my life real quick she's over in
yeah yeah yeah he's over in house where
she's pregnant in the car the worst is
when you kind of get caught up when if
there's a salesperson they're giving you
they're giving you the spiel about the
product and like you're acting like you
give a [ __ ] you're just like yeah I
don't I get for more than me really no
corn products this is all you know we
only use half a GM I do it whatever give
me the [ __ ] crackers let's go I'll
actually do you one better not only do I
double-dip on free samples at my old
growth store in Baltimore when I had
absolutely no money I they had a hot bar
I had two pieces of fried catfish every
time I shopped and I washed it down with
like I'd like a kind bar or something
for a single time just walking around
and I would throw it away I would I
would put it in the thing like I
actually was gonna pay for it and I
would just eat it and then I've just
thrown away at some point yeah I had a
whole system didn't steal on fried
catfish at the grocery store all time
low I think that that shouts out to the
giant on 33rd in Baltimore giant sound
operation Giants legit yeah I I know
what you know we were struggling growing
up but the one thing that my mom never
crossed a line on that I always
respected and that I always thought was
pretty trashy is people who eat the food
out of the cart while they're shopping
they start digging into it yeah you want
to taste a grape or something like that
short or but if you're walking around
with your hand in a [ __ ] box
cheez-its and you have it on like a
little thing in the cart your [ __ ]
garbage yeah well that you can't do that
around your children for sure because
that that is you know you're instilling
the wrong message but I will say I'm I'm
all personally I mean I won't as much
and like now like I'm not poor so I get
to just spend money on whatever I want
so I buy
I'll just buy snacks no matter what so I
don't I'll eat in the thing and pay for
it like a gentleman now but like I said
I'm eating catfish I'm cracking open
[ __ ] chips I'm just I would take my
great I would just take like one of a
can and like a candy bar I hadn't tasted
I'm like I'm interested in that just
take one of those and leave the
packaging I would eat the [ __ ] out of
that stuff oh yeah oh yeah big time it's
a big move for me as a kid was I would
always to go like did we bribed me with
a roll because I was a little fat kid
yeah get a roll from the deli while my
mom would food shop and I was like just
give me that big [ __ ] roll put me in
the front of that car and let me [ __ ]
chill absolutely what I love about that
is most kids it would be like some
dunkaroos [ __ ] maybe a lunchable some
gushers this kid wanted a [ __ ] Kaiser
is hilarious like that you you travelled
in back in time from the depression can
I have some flour and water on the tip
of my tongue mother and still to this
day you get me a soft roll with a cold
can of coke [ __ ] night dog hysterical
what is the brashness
your white-trash snack if I've ever
heard one
roll and I've crushed just rolls
probably not paying random the can of
coke is what's really disappointing
because what you're presenting is if
it's a meal with the roll with a little
butter it's like okay that's really good
I agree but you're talking roll with a
sweet drink that you're imagining that
you're eating a sandwich
I just don't have the meat today I'm
pretending it's a bologna [ __ ] what
about pets growing up what was the pet
situation over there we did not have any
we had we it was it was a very you know
densely populated house and we all had
asthma so it was like we could Mike we
wanted I think my little brother really
wanted a dog but we just could never we
had like a fish that no one that died
instantly but we really never we were
not a pets family and then once we moved
out my mom me and my brother when I went
to college one of my other brothers went
to college she got two cats to replace
us but but now they have those cats and
my brothers have cats and a dog in their
respective places but never no pets
growing up and I'm not I don't have pets
here either
you know a pet guy how long did that
fish tank sit empty in your house after
the fish died oh that's a great question
I think it's still there in the corner
yeah and my dad's office yeah the office
was literally like the layout of this
[ __ ] house is hysterical because it's
like kitchen and then there's like a
weird the kitchen and then there's like
to the right of it there's a raised the
rest of the house is raised like four
inches for some reason and then it's
like the office and then like where the
TV was and then just a cabinet full of
shoes but the shoe cabinet was there and
it made no sense my dad was a carpenter
and I think he designed it himself and
it just still to this day is one of the
least efficient uses of specially whose
shoes my life just a family shoes yeah
you think you'd be where you'd be that
would be where you would go and get your
shoes to leave the house well you have
your everyday shoes but again you have
you have to recognize your Foley we're
talking about there's six Greek people
that live here so it's like just just
Church shoes for the family takes up a
whole [ __ ] rack of of you know
cabinet and you
my mom's shoe you know what I mean like
we all played soccer so the soccer shoes
were down there was [ __ ] funny I know
that's a first that's an are you garbage
first
not I'm not doing it justice how
stupidly it's laid out it's really bad
there's two a fax machine there see
that's the warrior early fax adopters
and that was the last new technology
that graced our our household we'd have
a microwave so I was like 14 years old
yeah I did that when I went to get I
want to get an iPod and the guy
convinced me to get a zoom remember that
of course the competitor the big ass it
was like dude this is what you want I'm
like all right so that guy were like
rolled up to a part or like high school
thinking I was the coolest [ __ ] guy
and it was and I really tried to push
him like not better it's got more RAM or
whatever but yeah like anyone gives a
[ __ ]
nobody was buying into yeah you know
it's good because it's 80% cheaper you
know the mark of something popular in
capitalism is when it costs more than
[Laughter]
you have to pick one Fritos Cheetos or
Pringles mmm that's tough it says a lot
about you I'm gonna go ahead for yours
are out that's the first cut well no
because it's just they just they are if
I had to snack in definitely its Fritos
but I will say there they just don't
have them they don't have the highs
Fritos have a very high seal or high
floor low ceiling yes
Pringles I would say very high ceiling
but sometimes you're not in the mood for
them
Cheetos same thing to you know sometimes
get too salty yes [ __ ] if I had a she
knows she knows they're tough to have
with the sandwich I think surely it's
more of an appetizer yeah there well I
could spend what you just said and say
that Cheetos stand on their own in a way
that some others just might not
excellent you know
that is a [ __ ] review right there in
the world so earnestly just staring at a
dude
absolutely I'm gonna have to say in my
heart it's as much as I it's tough cuz I
love both I am gonna have to go cheeto
though person oh yeah I would say this
is the middle answer I think Pringles is
the classiest of the sure but you know I
just I some i tire of Pringles quickly
as much as I enjoy them like I just it's
it's not it's not I can't do it
indefinitely you know you can't put your
finger on it but there is something
missing from a Pringle I just don't know
what it is it might be left that it's
too thin I'm not sure and listen don't
get me wrong I'll crush rip I mean this
is not I'll I [ __ ] I [ __ ] with
prickly just I would just say
emotionally there's something to me
about a cheeto that resonates a little
more that again yeah I get it
frito is definitely the wrong answer
there Fritos tough absolutely although
one of the a delicacy and my high school
was the honey frito the honey barbecue
fries oh yeah the is the twist mixed
with salt and vinegar chips and you
[ __ ] put them all in a bag it was it
was all the rage at Baltimore
Polytechnic Institute in the mid-2000s
is that now is there a specific brand of
salt and vinegar I should be looking for
in this in this scenario yeah classic is
Utz primo gentlemen absolutely that's a
Baltimore thing to us you take pride in
our local I don't know Hanover PA I yeah
but it's PA Baltimore there's some
reason Baltimore has it's there's a real
pride with I think is the crab chip is a
nuts product then you sort of adopt it
but yeah Utz Utz definitely is like the
the the most ubiquitous chip I would say
in in Baltimore I don't know traction is
something else made their unbelief
really is something else incredible
right yeah it's like a it's like a tan
okay there is a there's a competitor
there is a there's a pretender a usurper
to the throne and that's hers has crab
chips they are not good I think the
silver batters might be the silver
backers I'm sorry to say if that's what
you're thinking of you've been you've
been lied to your whole life as to what
the best crab chip is it is 100% Utz you
know we're a big fan of at the fawley
house for sure crab chips yes yeah we're
a big huts family at the Foley house and
this is how garbage we are our move my
mom's move was always never individual
items she would get the Utz party mix
which I don't know if you know about
that horse in the tours right it's in
like the big white oh yes oh no see I
was thinking that oh yeah
well you said party mix I thought the
little the little bags of the party mix
but oh oh those are going with a little
snack packs [ __ ] good night yeah yes
I'll uh well they had Cheetos in there
too they had their own little Hot
Cheetos in the snack snack pack is from
memory if I can recall is the pretzel
put yourself in style can you remember
remember there's a corn chip for sure
there's a barbecue corn chips a barbecue
corn chip pretzel yeah you know look I
don't blank eat on the rest I think
that's just about it there's a plain
corn chip there's like a plain tortilla
chip yes and that's what I see and to
you you're gonna sit here and tell me
the cheeto is not the MVP of that
[ __ ] mix yeah all right I'll give you
that a hundred percent it doesn't belong
in there what doesn't belong in there
and has always left over at the end are
those [ __ ] pretzels get them out of
there
the person place it doesn't belong in a
party man big I used to go to the
parties and just eat the pretzels and
people thought I was weird
that is weird that is weird but you do
you do you know what I mean for for for
good to exist in the world there has to
be some evil and the pretzel the pretzel
is the bad in
to highlight how good everything else is
you know and sometimes I eat my pretzels
first feels like a reward be able to
have just Cheetos eating your vegetables
it really feels that way it really feels
that way philosophically oh I got one I
want to know at the house all right
growing up was there it was a multiple
there was multiple doors that get in I
would assume right yeah okay
were you the family who went in through
the front door or did you always use the
side or back door well I mean it was the
front door only because the back door
was just like the alley
it was just there's multiple doors in
the sense that you could in a fire
situation get out but there's really
only one and a man's or yeah yeah yes I
am that's out this sounds like a little
bit of an economic issue here we're a
side door to me is the height I couldn't
even imagine how I'm gonna through the
side door when I when I when we went to
a family I had a side door I was like I
think you don't even use it like I only
knew two families with that layout
growing up and and it knocked my socks
off every time the side door into the
kitchen is extremely sitcom yes that's a
great feeling in the side door and the
[ __ ] kitchens right there right there
Oh sneak a snack on your way out because
snack there's old iced tea in a picture
in the flood and fridge come on nothing
better all right do you like vanilla
coke yeah I do I do I'm a cherry
question cherry cherries theory of color
over vanilla but I I like I like a I you
you sent me loose on one of those
freestyle machines I can have a really
nice time oh that's trash sure you don't
know what kind of flavors in my coat is
Garbowsky oh those things are [ __ ]
garbage there's no way around that man
hey I'd find anybody mixing Fanta and
sprite and coke you're trash I just want
I'm listen me sometimes you want to diet
vanilla cherry barks root beer know what
I mean sometimes that's what you want
slice of lemon on this please why is
Powerade always in the mix that always
throws me off coloring with a meal who
showed up to the movie theater out of
breath the same way I in my little fat
head as a child thought pretzels was
vegetables I bet you there's somebody
who thinks you know what I'm not gonna
have soda today I'm gonna be healthy I'm
having power dude I thought that through
college I was in the cafeteria and they
had screaming cold red Gatorade out of
the fountain the best hangover so dude I
would had dinner I would just like have
chicken tenders and [ __ ] red Gatorade
and there was this dude who I was
friends with was in chickies you
shouldn't really drink you that bunch
Gatorade if you're not working out 64
ounces from the day sub he's 400 pounds
but his electrolytes are through the
roof oh yeah all right putting up
numbers absolutely I probably what he
got I'm curious to know
stavros when was the last time you did
either of the following smoked or peed
in a pool smoked in a pool or peed in
the pool okay you don't vote in general
cigarettes smoke a singer or urinated in
the pool when's the last time you did
either one of those jeez I'm trying to
think when I was in a pool I mean
whenever I was in a pool odds are I
pissed it questions answered let's not
let's not sit here this is this is one
of the foundational lives of our society
yes that we all know that none of us
piss in the pool and it's like I'm gonna
piss the most the time I'm gonna piss in
the pool I don't know what to tell you
it's a you know maybe not in a public I
don't know I don't know I'm a public
pool
waterpark classy resort [ __ ] oats you
know I don't give a [ __ ] I will lie
about that until um until I'm dead yeah
yeah in the pool oh dude I get
everywhere
I guess now if I if it's the pool with
access to like a tree I can piss on
out-of-print like out of its still trash
but it's like look I'm I'm I'm conscious
trash here I'm gonna pull my dick out
behind the grill and take a piss if
that's all right with you and they're
like think they just everyone tips their
cap at me like from the ocean I mean the
ocean that's there's no nothing like
that
well this comes up this has been coming
up a lot because I got out of the city
for the quarantine I've been down the
shore and like a lot of my family's down
so we're all on the beach and we'll just
like I got to take a piss instead of
walking you know the 10 blocks everybody
just goes in the water early just walk
to the water with like a cousin and just
go and I can be and drive here and talk
and walk out you can always tell you can
always tell who's pissin in the ocean
I'm not trying to hide it man I'm the
guy standing waist-deep you're their
waist-deep looking around and under man
no way I like the idea of you just sit
as like feet in but dick out into the
ocean that's that's a power move right
there that's a [ __ ] strong one
[Laughter]
beautiful all right I guess along that
line as well have you ever been to Ocean
City Maryland you know I have but it was
pretty late in life okay yes that is I
was my friend went to Rehoboth once I
will say we're Greeks are the one nice
thing we had access to was going to
Greece sure my family was there like
this the plane was expensive but once we
got there we didn't really dispense any
money guys show us we stayed for free
you know all that kind of stuff do at
Ocean City Maryland to us from Philly is
like we thought because we went to all
windows out Jersey just so we're like
y'all and
every couple of years everybody's family
would be in City Maryland free yourself
and it's just it's just [ __ ] garbage
from like you know 200 miles south
that's all that's so funny because it
was the exact opposite in Maryland it's
like truth when we treat ourselves we go
to Wildwood all quarantine have been in
Wildwood New Jersey I almost died on a
[ __ ] tilt-a-whirl in Wildwood as a
little kid when we went there there was
just some guy operating it did not give
a [ __ ] I mean my brothers had ridden it
it was like the only good ride and they
were all trash and so we had gotten used
to the rhythm of it of like oh we know
when it's you know it goes around five
times or whatever spins back and that's
what it's over and this guy just like
switched up the rhythm on us so we got
out of our thing and we're like time to
get back in line and then the [ __ ] comes
flying back at as we have to like DA it
was fun
we dive into like a teacup that wasn't
ours it was [ __ ] food they come in
and then and then my family went to
complain but they're just like yeah we
don't care yeah man who are you gonna
sue the [ __ ] the carnies down there
yeah though some of those rides were
sketchy throughout the 90s real [ __ ]
sketchy oh yeah brother on the on the
subject of amusement parks I'm curious
because geographically it's close to
where you are
uh-huh have you or any member of your
family ever gone on vacation or been to
the facility known as Busch Gardens
Colonial Williamsburg I believe I went
once as a really little kid but yeah it
was not we weren't a big theme park
family I will say that that's not a
theme park guy either you know like a
roller coaster not really huh and also
the theme parks in general I just I
don't know they're not for me yeah too
expensive lines bunch of [ __ ] people
I like I love the idea of them and I
love roller coasters but that's one of
those things where like you're you get
excited to go you go but then at some
point while you while you're there you
start looking around at the other
clientele if you will
and you're like you just feel bad you
like is that me they exactly don't they
look at me and think I'm Dom trash
because I think everyone's right nothing
worse of realizing the people you have
something in common with that happened
to me when I was like I mean I'm not a
big football guy anymore but when I was
younger I was you know I would and like
one year and you're like early 20s early
to mid twenties she's like going to bars
and watching games and I take it I
stopped doing that and then I came back
to visit a friend in Baltimore and she's
like me this out in Fed Hill you know
like whatever it's like a [ __ ] bar
area and just to be around the kinds of
people I was like I this is the worst
thing about sports is that the people it
bonds me with like I have something in
common with these people that in a few
short months will be defending Ray Rice
you know nothing like these people at me
share we we love the same thing and
that's that is part of what I don't like
about a amusement park I'll probably
I'll have to admit that's part of that
feeling yeah it's tough as well so you
hate about yourself in other people
amplified yeah for sure yeah nothing can
turn you off from being a sports fan
than another sports fan [ __ ] loser
shut up it's a [ __ ] relax you know
they're freaking out
yeah lose your [ __ ] and put your put
your child's college tuition on this
game and shut the [ __ ] up what's the way
they're meant to be enjoyed
get [ __ ] eat over eat and Gamble
uncontrollably
this is food heavy but if you're the
local mall and it's dinnertime you're in
the food court what is your one meal
you're gonna get great [ __ ] question
Kevin Ryan I am if I'm at the food court
I don't know who I am going I don't know
if this is probably a regional chain but
it's it's called Sarco Japan and I'm a
teriyaki guy at a food I'm a teriyaki
guy through and through and a rack of
crap in fact we just you just said it
and now I like I want that like I wish I
was in a mall food court right now love
Sark ooh double-double me
99 cents do it you got to do it the the
teriyaki chicken is the number one food
sample of all time exactly there's never
not a guy standing out there with
[ __ ] toothpicks and chicken teriyaki
oh yeah and there has never been a time
that I or any member of my family have
ever walked by that and not [ __ ]
dipped in it 100% and not only this I go
to get that one first and then of course
I have all the other samples pretend
like I'm thinking it over full well
knowing I'm ending up at Sark ooh I'm
ending up getting teriyaki but I'll get
the orange chicken I'll take a little
cut a piece of Stromboli
I'll get your [ __ ] hopes up yeah
guess what at the end of the day I know
where I'm going
let's continue this Rouge I [ __ ] love
that growing up when you went swimming
did you wear a t-shirt in the pool
stavi hmm you know there was a brief
period of before I was liberated then I
was a t-shirt kid but I think I found I
don't know I had like a in the middle of
my childhood I was just like I'm gonna
play this up for laughs I think I was
quickly but sure I was I started as I
had a brief tenure as a t-shirt kid but
you know it's very liberating when you
finally when you're when you're finally
like you know what [ __ ] this oh yeah
because that wasn't real because we're
all Kevin Kevin was a chubby kid that's
that's a real tough summer man when you
start to start feel that and you know
like I get a pretty shirt on
then you're in there and the shirt you
feel we're doing the shirt the worst is
getting out do when you that sucks and
it creates
yes I try I try and live my life as is
almost a beacon of hope for the for the
pool kid t-shirt kids in the pools right
there you go I want you to know that you
could be fat as hell take it on like
just take it off take it uh celebrate
your little celebrate your little
titties mm-hmm it's not a big deal it
feels so much better to take that off
and swim just in the nice water without
a [ __ ] [ __ ] graphic yeah brutal
yeah yeah white t-shirt as a child I
grew into my nipples exactly all right I
think I only got one more here baby is
your bed Cara Lee in the corner of your
room okay you've graduated to the middle
I graduated middle of the room yeah
that's a mature step once you like I
felt like an aristocrat when I did it
yeah should I stand or something oh yeah
I got an I said I saw I saw I don't know
a tweet or something where it said like
a bed should have two for two eggs two
forms of egress and it blew my mind cuz
I was like what
but that you're [ __ ] they got the
bottom of the left side taking up all
the taking up all this extra space I
don't [ __ ] get worried what is your
gaming chair go I got the black light
set up in the corner right I'm crowding
my [ __ ] I'm crowding my Boondock Saints
poster dude I'm out of that questionable
is anybody out there anybody out there
just like the t-shirts if you're
listening and your bed is up against the
wall like that move it into the center I
swear it instantly changes
outlook and and and the way you just
operate well it's also like what do you
we want it we think for like activities
and stuff like what are you doing if
you're not 12
you don't need more space in your right
you just need room to get dressed and
you know put a TV and that's it
the dream is to not have any I mean we
all live in New York especially it's
like you live like a [ __ ] animal so
the dream is for me all I want is a room
just a bed room bed [ __ ] nightstand
no a throw a [ __ ] human if like get
get give me give me some [ __ ]
essential oils give me some can do my
yeah I need I need a [ __ ] sanctuary
yeah that's my dream is to get there but
you know for the time being yeah cuz as
New Yorkers we live in our room so you
like your room is your house you know
right right right in your room you watch
TV
yeah lavender scented pillows all day I
love lavender baby no put you right to
sleep
alright one more I got two more just
we're gonna let you get out of here but
I feel like the that the the squad would
be upset if I didn't ask you these two
skaters who babe onesie surgery any wife
you were definitely one of the most
requested yes let's hear it let's do
baby growing up would you ever have milk
with dinner where you served melted
dinner no absolutely not
there's a [ __ ] gentleman dog purse
that's I can't even to me I don't know
what is your explanation of them yes for
cereal orders for dessert and I am NOT
to he I don't want to hear anything else
it is not a savory you know I do not
want anything savory when it comes to
milk with the exception of like a cream
of crab soup or clam chowder with that
shrinking class okay wait you mean
without here washing down meatloaf with
[ __ ] milk sub yeah [ __ ]
why are you mindfully you're out of your
furry slowly if it was racially
acceptable they would haven't
jeonse for you you've never ordered
filet mignon and a [ __ ] glass of 2%
it's it's disgust I'm honestly I can't
even that that question makes me mad
don't spaghetti Matty you know if you
know what grace is feel towards you I
knew a racist feel towards people of
color towards you right now folia no
milk and spaghetti are you out of your
[ __ ] mind just have jeans like a
regular person I'm doing more dairy this
is [ __ ] up dude I hate that question
you asked me the next one dude so many
people's favorite meal is milk and
spaghetti it's crazy
it's give me a list about that I'm gonna
do a little little [ __ ] genocide
right now I'm get them all cancer
they're about to get their fat to get a
[ __ ] there better get a letter in the
mail for a free train ride I gotta say
man I'm [ __ ] stunned by your answer I
feel betrayed as well nah I can't do
this tragedy [ __ ] up I hate that all
right
the last question that I'll ask you and
I think I know which way you're gonna
lean is ketchup and syrup after you open
a bottle of ketchup where does it reside
in the refrigerator or in the cabinet
ketchup in the fridge excellent and
after you open a bottle of maple syrup
where does that reside huh hmm
interesting I guess I don't i i i i
don't want to pretend like i have
because I came on real strong about the
milk I can't beat I can't sit here and
pretend I have strong feelings about the
maple syrup okay I've had it both ways
growing up and I guess now that I think
about it I kind of like how how [ __ ]
thick it gets in the fridge but
currently my syrup is in though is not
is in the cabinet yes and it's more of a
it's more of a because I don't really
eat syrup you know like that so it's
like in fact I don't even think I have
syrup it's like an old roommate went to
Canada and left like some Canadian like
some good
[ __ ] I just kept it and I have yet to
use it and when I do use it it'll be a
special day but right now it's serious
it's sealed in a cabinet so I don't want
to sit here and lie to you and say that
I'm good but if it's the real stuff when
you open it up you got to keep that
stuff cold the good stuff you got to
keep cold but yes good ain't your my miz
and miz's butter oh yeah yeah let me
tell you something about the good stuff
cuz I'm a child that grew up on [ __ ]
Mrs Butterworth and all that crap
and I remember once or twice my mom
coming back from a trip and her breaking
out the real stuff and I was like get
this [ __ ] out of my [ __ ] face but now
as an adult right real maple syrup [ __ ]
yeah trip man daddy you know what that
something else I agree and I agree that
it has to go in the fridge cuz if it's a
little runny err yeah then they're like
high fructose [ __ ] and I personally I
think there's something in your heart
that says I want that you know I want I
want it thick so I'm I'm I'm you running
me over on on team fridge okay fir firm
for maple syrup for regular maples for
regular serum its cabinet gotcha yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] what I can't pretend I
care one way or the other I got one too
before this is another this is another
big one yeah hit me hit me butter oh
where do you keep the butter is it on
the counter is it on the fridge fridge
thank you you think you know a guy meet
this guy great guy you like them fridge
fridge for sure
dude there's animals just keep the
butter out on the on the cabin I listen
I've heard of that and I guess that it
people say it doesn't go bad or whatever
but it's like why take the risk
what do you do it's Dairy Dairy it's
dairy I agree with you yes I agree 100%
I just gave you a couple of points in my
book that in the milk for dinner
buddy this guy's give me president I
can't do that it gave them points to be
in class but I gotta tell you you don't
you don't [ __ ] you don't rise to the
top without hurting people and you hurt
me you'd add a little style you wasn't
drinking a big glass of milk and he
butter his butter was on the counter
with a nice fresh rolled spreadin nicely
yeah the spreading is the one place
people get me on that and I have left it
out in the past and I've enjoyed the
spread but there's just something about
it I need to have it in the [ __ ]
fridge I've come to terms with I never
had it but if you have it you can it's
gotta sleep in the fridge if you click
it out in the morning and keep it on the
counter that's fine but to me that's
more [ __ ] up the console temperature
shifts cosine the other I don't know
yeah and maybe this is a [ __ ] this this
is also a thing we're the kinds of
families that are drinking milk or going
through butter it doesn't have time to
go back no time to get back to your
Foley's [ __ ] it sitting down having a
[ __ ] ribeye and taking a spoonful of
butter and his milk and like it's
Nesquik watch and washing down lasagna
with it all lasagna come on what you're
saying is horrific but anyway the
fellows I actually have to run kind of
soon so ladies how he is
Stav I gotta say people might [ __ ]
fight me on this or whatever or say that
word that you know we're just being a
class all the way
what are you talkin garbaggio
I agree and you know what I think that's
this is exactly this is the duality of
Who I am
yeah one person thinks on class the
other person thinks I'm trash and
they're both right I think that's I
think that's what it is I'm the swirl
baby anything you want you want the
folks to know before you get out of here
anything coming up no no really I mean
no no dates obviously but yes nabhi
solves your problems is a new show I
started I do a live on Twitch every
Friday at 6 o'clock and also it goes up
on YouTube every week so check out my
youtube channel I'm doing a bunch of
[ __ ] over there so to sort of try and
replace the end up comedy which is me
but yeah boys that's it for me thank you
so much thank you so much man go ahead
and get out of here do your thing
shakey this is great there's so much fun
thank you buddy
I'll talk to you guys soon see you pal
hippie you got anything for the gang
yeah just make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes and also subscribe
on youtube the full videos available in
YouTube even if you don't [ __ ] watch
the video just go subscribe anyway juice
those numbers
yes sir gang we love every each and
every every each and every one of you
the [ __ ] am I saying I don't know [ __ ]
you guys we got big things coming down
the line we're so glad that everybody's
with us [ __ ] good times here on are
you garbage come back and see us next
week
see you guys